.
(Mann) Bela,
lässt du Interessierte rein?
Zürich-West.
Mitten in der Stadt lebt hier
eine Gruppe von Frauen und Männern
völlig anders als üblich.
Die Gruppe
lebt nicht in einer normalen Wohnung,
sie lebt in einer Halle.
Beim sog. Hallenwohnen
bauen die Bewohnerinnen und Bewohner
eine Gewerbehalle zum Lebensraum um.
MIT TELETEXT-UNTERTITELUNG
Mit Bewohnern und Ateliernutzern
gehen hier rund 20 Personen
ein und aus.
Je nach Nutzung
bezahlen sie 200-700 Fr. Monatsmiete.
* Sphärische Gitarrenklänge *
(Mann) Das ist hier auf 700 m2.
Wir zahlen 10'000 Fr. pro Monat.
Das Ziel war, die Halle
möglichst offen zu bespielen.
Mit rollbaren Spaces,
in denen man schlafen
und Atelierarbeitsplätze haben kann.
Das ist mein Roll-Space.
Ich nenne sie die Fluft -
weil es so ein luftig-leichtes
Schlafzimmer ist.
Wenn man drin ist,
fühlt man sich aber sehr geborgen.
Ich habe links und rechts vom Bett
Vorhänge, die man schliessen kann.
Der Respekt ist auch da:
Ist der Vorhang zu, heisst das, dass
ich schlafe und allein sein will.
Dann kommt
auch selten jemand klopfen.
Das funktioniert -
inkl. der Respekt anderer.
Ich bin auch seit Jahren
nichts anderes mehr gewöhnt.
Wenn man neu kommt, muss man
sich schon erst dran gewöhnen.
Eine Wohnung könnte ich mir leisten,
aber es bringt mir nichts,
die eigenen Wände zu haben.
Gut, im Moment habe ich sie,
die habe ich selbst gebaut.
Deshalb möchte ich auch so wohnen:
um meine eigenen Wände zu bauen.
Ich möchte nicht mieten oder kaufen.
* Ruhiges Gitarrenschrummen *
Die Möglichkeiten, die das Leben
in einer Halle mit sich bringt,
sind der wichtigste Grund,
so zu leben.
Ich hatte lange einen Ort gesucht,
der für mich ...
... Wohnen und Atelier vereint.
* Stimmengewirr,
leise Gitarrenklänge *
Brauchen wir einen neuen Ort,
um zusammenzukommen,
können wir eine Sofanische bauen -
oder man baut eine Bühne
für eine Veranstaltung.
Man kann den Ort
nach den Bedürfnissen verändern,
die man erkennt.
* Stimmengewirr *
Ich musste abschauen,
wo die Augen sind.
Es kommt
schon ziemlich aufs Team an.
Meine Mitbewohner sind meine
Freunde - eine Grundvoraussetzung.
Sonst funktioniert es nicht.
Wenn du das nicht sagen kannst,
musst du dir was anderes suchen.
Wenn das wirklich so ist,
ist es eine familiäre Stimmung,
und man teilt viel miteinander.
Eine Art familiäres Sippenwohnen.
* Leise Gespräche, Lachen *
Mätti und ich fanden immer:
Wenn Kinder, dann nicht,
wenn wir
in einer kleinen Wohnung sind
und nur
zu dritt, viert oder fünft leben.
Wir wollten mit anderen Menschen
und Inputs verbunden bleiben.
Hier haben wir sehr viele,
sehr verschiedene Inputs
und geniessen das meistens sehr.
Wenn ich Bela oder Amun
irgendwohin bringen muss,
finde ich immer jemanden,
der 15 Min.,
30 Min. oder länger aufpassen kann.
Das Hallenwohnen mit Kindern
bedingte,
dass die Familie nebst dem Rollzimmer
auch ein abgetrenntes Zimmer
im hinteren Teil der Halle hat.
Dass wir dieses Zimmer hatten,
wurde dann schon sehr wichtig.
Gerade am Anfang -
und auch jetzt manchmal.
Der Rückzug als ganze Familie
an einen Ort ist super.
Andere Familien können sich
das hier nicht vorstellen.
Und ich finde:
"Oje, wie wird das wohl?"
"Ich kann mir das gar nicht vor-
stellen", für die andere Situation.
* Melancholische Gitarrenklänge *
Diese Art zu wohnen ist momentan
nur in Zwischennutzung möglich.
Der Mietvertrag war von Beginn weg
auf 3 1/2 Jahre befristet.
In wenigen Monaten müssen die
Bewohnerinnen und Bewohner ausziehen.
An einer sonntäglichen WG-Sitzung
wird der Zeitplan
des kommenden Abbaus diskutiert.
(Sigi)
Wir werden so viel zu tun haben.
Wir werden Stress haben,
Party machen -
ich habe Respekt vor dieser Zeit.
Und dann eine Zwischennutzung vor-
bereiten, umsetzen und verhandeln.
Ich würde mich da eher zurückhalten.
Ich finde ...
Das Osterwochenende
würde sich anbieten,
um noch einmal über alle Etagen
ein grosses Fest zu machen.
Dann müsste man aber noch aufräumen,
am Mittwoch den Rest wegbringen,
am Donnerstag
die Schüssel abgeben.
Schliesslich ist die Frage, wer am
Montag noch das Material wegräumt.
(Frau) Ihr.
Am Dienstag dann, oder?
- Ja.
Wenn alle ihren persönlichen Kram
bis am Donnerstag, 22.,
weggebracht haben,
dann hätte man ein Wochenende,
Freitag bis Sonntag,
um abzubauen,
umzuziehen und einzulagern.
Während die meisten als Nächstes
in eine Wohnung ziehen werden,
hat Mätti grössere Pläne.
Das Projekt neigt sich dem Ende zu.
Wir haben hier 3 1/2 Jahre
wunderbar gelebt und gewirkt.
Wir hoffen, in Zukunft im Zollhaus
in einem längerfristigeren,
gesetzteren Rahmen sein zu können.
Wir möchten aber die gleichen
Gestaltungsmöglichkeiten
und -freiheiten
wie in der temporären Nutzung haben.
Ganz in der Nähe
des Zürcher Hauptbahnhofs,
wo Bauland knapp und begehrt ist,
entsteht die Siedlung Zollhaus.
Bauherrin ist die Zürcher
Wohnbaugenossenschaft Kalkbreite.
Hier soll zum ersten Mal
offiziell das Hallenwohnen
in einem Wohngebäude
angeboten werden.
Haus A, Haus B
und das kleine Haus C.
Oben im Haus A
wird das Hallenwohnen stattfinden.
Das Hallenwohnen ist nur im 3. OG.
Hier ist die eine Halle,
die auf den Innenhof schaut,
und hier die andere,
die auch Anschluss zum Innenhof hat.
Sie schauen auf alle Seiten raus.
An dieser Lage, am Bahnhof,
haben wir auch
eine soziale Verantwortung,
etwas anderes hinzustellen
als 08/15-Wohnungsbau,
Rendite abschöpfen.
Es war ein Arbeiterquartier,
und wir wollen
etwas Gescheites daraus machen.
Wir hatten mal
ein Bild eines Bienenhauses.
Wenn wir schon
diese prominente Lage haben,
sollen viele ein- und ausgehen -
das soll auch gefördert werden.
Also wollten wir
Grossgruppen ansprechen,
entsprechend grosse Wohnungen bauen.
Wir wollten auch durchlässiges Ge-
werbe und neue Wohnideen aufnehmen.
Die erste Siedlung
der Genossenschaft Kalkbreite
hat neue Massstäbe
für alternative Wohnformen
und nachhaltiges,
autofreies Leben gesetzt.
Hier besucht Mätti
eine Besprechung zum Hallenwohnen.
Auch andere Gruppen
sind interessiert.
Hoi, Mätti.
Wir warten auch noch auf Andreas,
sind noch nicht ganz vollständig.
Herzlich willkommen zur zweiten
Zwischenbesprechung Hallenwohnen,
in der es darum geht,
welche Fragen noch im Raum stehen
für die Bewerbung, die wir
auf den 1. Dezember erwarten.
Ich habe mir überlegt:
Wäre es theoretisch möglich,
Seilzüge zu installieren, mit denen
man ein Bett hochziehen könnte?
Das wäre möglich, okay.
Jemand in unserer Gruppe
hatte die Idee,
gebrauchte Container als Wohn-
einheiten in die Halle einzubauen.
Das Problem ist einfach:
Es muss rückbaubar sein.
Wenn du uns fragst, ob man
die Container reinschieben kann,
bevor wir die Fassaden montieren,
dann müsstest du zahlen,
wenn man
die ganze Fassade abbauen muss,
um die Container wieder auszubauen.
Raus kriegst du sie sicher,
du kannst sie auseinanderflexen.
* Lachen *
In der Wohnung!
Bei den Hallenprojekten,
die ich kenne,
hat man ein halbes Jahr gebaut,
in der Baustelle gelebt.
In den Projekten, die ich kenne,
hatte man eine mietzinsfreie Zeit.
Bei der Konzeptbewerbung
geht es darum,
dass sich Gruppen bilden,
die zusammen wohnen möchten.
Sie müssen aber
nicht nur darüber reden,
sondern in dieser Phase
auch schon rausfinden,
welche soziale Durchmischung
sie haben,
wie dicht sie wohnen,
wie sie sich finanzieren werden
und wie sie so auch über zehn Jahre
werden wohnen können,
mit Mieterwechseln usw.
Es wird sicher anspruchsvoll
für die Gruppen,
den formalen Teil zu bestimmen.
Wie finanzieren sie es?
Wie gelten sie
ihre Eigenleistung untereinander ab?
Welche Regeln
etablieren sie untereinander?
Was tun sie, wenn jemand
sehr viel gearbeitet hat
und nach zwei Jahren - wer weiss -
nach Berlin auswandert?
Das kann es alles geben im Leben.
Dass der dann angemessen entschädigt
wird oder etwas davon hat.
Damit dies klar ausgesprochen ist
und die Gruppe nicht beim ersten
Wechsel auseinanderfällt.
Es hat immer wieder
kleine Konflikte gegeben.
Über die grossen Konflikte
sprechen wir natürlich nicht gern.
Das Thema wollen wir nicht wieder
aufrollen - es wurde auch emotional.
Letztlich
hatten wir ein gutes Team zusammen,
das nicht mehr
so viele grosse Konflikte hat.
Und mit den kleinen
können wir umgehen.
* Stimmengewirr *
Das ist auch der Nachteil.
Es ist sehr dicht, man ist
mit allen Vibes direkt konfrontiert.
Man kriegt mit,
wenn es jemandem schlecht
oder besonders gut geht, und man
selbst nicht auf dem Level ist.
Man kriegt sehr viel mit
vom Kollektiv.
Es kann super sein,
dass jemand um 1 Uhr noch findet,
er koche Langusten für alle.
Das ist super,
wenn du dann noch wach bist
und Lust auf Langusten hast.
Wenn du gerade
Schwangerschaftsübelkeit hast,
findest du es nicht so lustig,
am nächsten Morgen
in die Küche zu kommen.
Und äh ...
Dasselbe gilt mit den Kindern.
Der ganze Stress, der dazukommt -
waschen, kochen, putzen ...
Und dann hat jemand die Banane ge-
gessen, die ich extra gekauft habe.
Das kann einen nerven.
Dafür ist dann mal Essen übrig,
weil jemand gerade gekocht hat,
dann musst du nicht
mehr Abendessen kochen.
* Stimmengewirr *
Aufgewachsen
sind die Bewohnerinnen und Bewohner
wie die meisten Leute konventionell.
Ich bin in Zollikerberg in einem
bürgerlichen Setting aufgewachsen.
Mein Vater war Arzt, war geprägt
von der Krankheit seines Vaters.
Eine menschliche Komponente
war also da.
In einer 60er-Jahre-Blocksiedlung
direkt am Wald.
Man hatte viele Freiheiten,
40 Kinder, die Verstecken spielten.
Weil es eine neue Siedlung war,
gab es viele Familien.
Der Wald, die Natur - Platz.
Ich habe früher ohne Ende
Fussball gespielt,
bin auf dem Fussballplatz
rumgerannt, habe Indianer gespielt.
Sonst war ich aber
ein Streber in der Schule.
Im Gymnasium konnte ich
aus meiner Rolle ausbrechen.
Wir sind eine recht normale Familie.
Eltern, zwei Söhne
im Einfamilienhaus mit Garten.
Dann bin ich mal ausgezogen -
relativ früh.
Und ich bin nie mehr
nach Zofingen zurückgezogen.
Ich lernte es in Winterthur kennen,
als ich im Studentenwohnheim war -
das war ein Riesenchaos.
Logisch - und es war viel los:
30 Leute auf engem Raum.
Danach wollte ich nichts mehr
anderes - und es macht Spass.
(Mann) Das ist ein rolling space,
aber ohne Räder.
Alex hat ein System designt
und gebaut.
Wir drehen hier ...
* Metallisches Klackern *
... die vier Beine kommen raus
und alles hebt sich um so viel an.
Wir können Räder drunterschieben
und so das Zimmer bewegen.
Das braucht viel Kraft.
* Metallisches Klackern *
* Leichte Gitarrenklänge *
Weiterdrehen!
Hat jede Partei 12 m2,
kann man alles in eine Hälfte
der Halle schieben
und die andere
wird frei für Veranstaltungen.
Nach hinten?
Man kann sie aufstellen.
Man muss mobil sein -
auf Rädern, irgendwie tragbar.
Im Normalfall breiten wir uns
so aus, dass jeder 25 m2 hat.
* Schräge Tangoklänge *
Regelmässig öffnen
die Hallenbewohner/-innen
ihren privaten Raum für
einen grösseren Kreis von Menschen
und veranstalten Konzerte,
Ausstellungen,
Theateraufführungen und Performances.
* Treibende Balkanklänge *
Die halb-öffentlichen
Veranstaltungen
waren immer ein Thema - dass
das nicht nur für uns ein Raum ist,
um gross zu leben, sondern
dass es ein offener Raum sein soll,
in den man reinkommen
und etwas konsumieren,
aber auch Ideen einbringen
und mitmachen kann.
* Anschwellende und abebbende
Trommelklänge *
(Monoton) Bending, rising, falling,
twisting, turning ... tilting ...
* Sphärische, gruselige Klänge *
* Wilde Technomusik *
Das Beste zum Abschalten
ist natürlich,
sich mit anderen auszutauschen.
Ich finde: Je mehr, desto besser,
desto mehr Inputs.
Die lenken dich von der täglichen,
hektischen Arbeit ab.
* Zögerliche Gitarrenklänge *
Ich bin ein Büromensch.
Ich zeichne Pläne,
erstelle Konzepte.
Ich arbeite viel.
Ein 100-%-Job - im Moment betreue
ich vier Projekte gleichzeitig.
Das beschäftigt einen schon.
In der Freizeit
muss man abschalten können.
Ich bin eher der, der viel arbeitet.
* Jauchzer *
(Frau) Ich kann nicht mehr!
Falsche Richtung, Sigi! Ah!
* Surren, Tontest *
Es geht in 2-3 Min. weiter
bei der grossen Bühne.
Ein rauschendes Fest, z.B. -
der ganze Stress vom Aufbau,
Organisieren und Putzen ...
Aber trotzdem merkt man beim Putzen:
Das war toll,
hat uns wieder mal zusammengebracht,
war ein rauschender Moment,
der einen prägt.
Das sind so Höhepunkte,
die man im Leben zu einer
Perlenkette aneinanderreihen an.
* Mitreissende Klänge *
In einer Waldhütte
in der Nähe von Zürich
verbringt Mätti ein Wochenende
mit einer neuen Gruppe von Leuten,
mit denen er an der Bewerbung fürs
Hallenwohnen im Zollhaus arbeitet.
Wir sind jetzt wieder
in der Bedürfnisdiskussion,
und die ist grundlegend.
Man muss diese Bedürfnisse
am Schluss
in diese zwei Hallen
plus Cluster reinpacken können.
Bei mir ist am Hallenwohnen
v.a. die Halle das Interessante -
der grosse, hohe, weite Raum,
den man verschieden nutzen kann.
Was ich aber brauche - das kann
eine Wabe, auch sehr klein sein -
ist ein isolierter, blickdichter
Schlafraum mit guter Luft.
Eine organisch wachsende Komponente
braucht auch Platz.
Wenn man etwas probiert,
das nicht funktioniert,
dann macht man es anders.
Ich finde die Idee von
einem gemeinsamen Kleiderschrank,
der zu einem Kleiderraum wird,
ziemlich toll.
So die Idee ...
... dass man sein T-Shirt
und seinen Pulli auswählt
und vielleicht
noch jemanden antrifft.
"Hey, rot heute?
Ist doch kein roter Tag."
... und das Spielzimmer ...
Ich stelle mir das als
dreidimensionale Konstruktion vor,
mit Leitern und Hängebrücken
dazwischen -
ein Cluster für die Kinder,
eine Tabuzone für uns,
ausser es stirbt gerade wer.
(Mann) Also für alle Kinder
oder nur deine?
Nein, für alle.
Das meine ich, Gemeinschaftszone.
Und die Grundfläche des Kinder-
paradieses? - So gross wie möglich.
Ich war einmal in einem Atelierhaus
mit einem offenen WC.
Man konnte am Tisch sitzen
und aufs WC schauen.
Ich habe gemerkt, dass das wohl
auch nicht funktionieren würde.
* Bewegte Gitarrenklänge *
Die Erfahrungen
in der Praxis des Hallenwohnens
müssen hier den Weg
in ein theoretisches Konzept finden.
Meine Vorstellung ist,
dass man das Schlafen
auf ein Minimum reduzieren kann
und dadurch einen grossen, öffent-
lichen, allgemeinen Raum gewinnt.
Wenn man ein Ideal von absoluter
Fairness anstreben würde,
müsste man eine extrem komplizierte
Kalkulation vornehmen.
Das ist eine hohe Miete,
die generiert werden muss -
der Platz ist kostbar.
Kostbar bedeutet:
Die Monatsmiete bei beiden Hallen
beträgt für 300 m2 ca. 9'000 Fr.
Die Diskussionen,
wie der Raum genutzt
und die Miete verteilt werden soll,
dauern bis spät in die Nacht.
Wir können uns nicht mehr leisten,
mehr Grünfläche zu verbauen.
Wir sollen verdichteter bauen -
einige finden in die Höhe,
andere enger,
weitere finden, wir sollten
weniger Platz pro Person brauchen.
Ich finde:
Wir sollen den bestehenden Raum
zeitlich gestaffelt
und intelligenter nutzen.
Das ist ein Hallenprojekt,
das dies ermöglichen würde.
Dass der Raum von verschiedenen
Menschen genutzt wird,
aber nicht gleichzeitig.
Wie ihr wisst, werden wir,
wenn das mit dem Zollhaus
und dem Hallenwohnen klappt,
wieder ein Hallenprojekt aufbauen.
Ich vermute,
dass wir alles Brauchbare bunkern
und dort wieder nutzen werden.
Wenn wir den Zuschlag kriegen ...
Wir haben hier gemeinsam gearbeitet
und vielleicht hättet ihr Lust,
da wieder mitzumachen.
Da besteht eine Möglichkeit.
- (Frau) Cool.
Es war eine Riesenarbeit.
- Ich habe es gesehen, ja.
Habt ihr es angeschaut?
Viel rechnen, aber auch ...
Ich finde,
es ist ziemlich gut geworden.
Das Zollhaus ist nichts für mich,
weil es mir zu weit weg, zu genau
geplant, zu kompliziert ist.
Es ist super, wie die Kalkbreite.
Mit super Grundsätzen
und Ideologien,
Diversifikation und Hallenwohnen -
das klingt alles gut.
Aber es ist so krass
im Konzept eingebunden,
dass es die Freiheit beschneidet.
Ich hätte lieber einfach eine Halle,
einige Freunde
und eine Bohrmaschine - los!
Das wäre mehr mein Ding.
43 Seiten.
29 Personen.
Wir haben sehr lange
daran gearbeitet, in der Retraite.
Wir konnten auch stark
auf dem Konzept von hier aufbauen,
es anpassen und ergänzen
mit der neuen Gruppe.
Morgen ist die Deadline - am
1. Dezember müssen wir einreichen.
Mit meinem Job, in dem ich
auch eine Stressphase habe ...
Ich werde den
jetzt eh noch machen müssen.
In letzter Zeit, seit dieser Phase,
schlafe ich nicht mehr als 3-4 Std.
Jetzt merke ich das langsam.
Es ist der Tag
der Bewerbungspräsentation
vor der Kalkbreite-Jury.
Mätti ist schon da.
Sein Arbeitsort ist nämlich
in der Kalkbreite-Siedlung.
Seit 17 Jahren arbeitet er als
Umweltwissenschaftler für Greenpeace.
Um uns Gehör zu verschaffen,
haben wir z.B. eine grosse Statue
nach Davos getragen.
Gerechtigkeit nach Davos bringen,
ans WEF tragen.
Kurz vor dem Start
des diesjährigen WEF in Davos
hat Greenpeace International
einen Report veröffentlicht ...
Hoi, Andreas.
- Hey, Mätti.
Ich bringe dir die beiden Mützen
und die Mobility-Karte zurück.
Es ist prekär,
aber deshalb auch toll.
Es ist sehr intensiv.
Man hat mit Greenpeace die globale,
aber auch ganz lokale Ebene.
Man hat zudem eine Zukunftsvision
Wohnen, wie ich sie mir vorstelle.
Deshalb hoffen wir, dass es heute
mit der Präsentation gut geht.
Jetzt entscheidet sich,
ob Mättis Gruppe mit dem Namen Zur
Wolke eine Zukunft im Zollhaus hat.
* Stimmengewirr *
(Eva) Das sind wir.
Wir sind 29 Personen: zehn Frauen,
elf Männer und acht Kinder.
Die Familienhalle
ist v.a. für familiäres Leben.
Gestaltet würde es durch modulare
und mobile Familientürme.
(Frau) Wichtig zu erwähnen:
Wir haben
ein Grossraumbad und -WC geplant,
das für mehrere Personen
angelegt ist.
Das ist genau damit angedacht,
v.a. dass wir diese beiden Hallen
unterschiedlich gestalten wollen.
Das ist im Konzept
alles beschrieben.
Wir haben auch das Gefühl,
wir brauchen diese Wohnung,
weil sie
gewisse Bedürfnisse abdeckt,
die sonst nicht abgedeckt werden.
Wir setzen darauf -
und haben in unserer Kerngruppe
gemeinsam beschlossen -,
dass jeder ein Startkapital
in den Verein einbringt.
Das wollen wir
in einer Amortisationszeit
von zehn bis 15 Jahren zurückzahlen.
Wir haben
mit 22'000 Fr. pro Kopf gerechnet.
Ihr seid auch bereit,
das gesamte Mietzinsrisiko
für zwei Hallen und eine Wohnung
zu tragen
und für den Leerstand aufzukommen?
Ihr seid 29 Personen - in
den drei Jahren kann viel passieren.
Könnt ihr es tragen?
Wie verpflichtet ihr die Leute,
beim Projekt mitzumachen?
Der Verein steht,
wir verpflichten uns.
Ich musste das auch überlegen.
In der Kerngruppe wurde das öfter
diskutiert: Man ist dann dabei.
Wir hören uns noch eine weitere
Gruppe an und hörten schon andere.
Es gibt eine Auswahl.
In den nächsten Tagen werdet ihr
eine Rückmeldung erhalten.
(Nina Schneider) Es sind jetzt
drei Konzepte im Rennen.
Eine Gruppe Innenarchitektur-
studenten ist dabei.
Das ist total interessant,
auch weil sie
mit ihrem Ausbaukonzept
sehr strukturell
an die Halle herangehen.
Man merkt aber:
Durch das Atelierarbeiten
haben sie viel Wohn-
und Arbeitserfahrung im Kollektiv.
Da bringen sie einiges mit.
(Frau) Man denkt an viele Leute
und günstiges Wohnen -
das löst sich hier nicht ein.
Dann haben wir ein ganz anderes
Konzept, das sich um Familie dreht.
In dieser Gruppe sind
je zur Hälfte Erwachsene und Kinder.
Sie haben ein konservativeres
Konzept von Ausbau,
weil sie wissen, dass es
Ruhezonen und Abgrenzung braucht.
Aber durchaus auch überzeugend.
(Frau) Ein Mittagstisch
wäre auch eine Idee.
Statt vier Küchen
benötigen wir eine,
aber die würde
vielleicht doppelt so viel kosten.
Wir sind jetzt auch offen
und möchten, dass Senioren
von Anfang an dabei sein können.
Ich hatte Respekt
beim Zollhaus-Projekt,
weil man sich einigen muss,
wie es sein soll
und das uns die nächsten ...
... 15-20 Jahre gefallen soll.
Oder dass es zumindest
für länger ist.
Ich habe etwas Angst, dass man dann
nicht so wilde Dinge probieren mag.
* Gedämpfte rassige Balkanmusik *
Wir haben am 1. Februar eine Mail
der Auswahlkommission erhalten.
Da steht: Bla, bla, bla ...
"... angesichts
dieser umfangreichen Vorbehalte
können wir das Konzept Zur Wolke
im Bewerbungsprozess
nicht weiter berücksichtigen."
Und äh, ja ...
Das ist natürlich
mit aller Härte eingeschlagen.
Wir sind wirklich
aus allen Wolken gefallen -
so kann man das sagen.
Und äh ...
Ja ... Also ...
Am Boden zerstört.
Die ersten Tage
haben wir uns einfach verkrochen
und viel geschlafen.
Ich persönlich,
natürlich mit meiner Familie,
meiner Frau
und den beiden Kindern ...
Dort hätte sich
eine logische Fortsetzung
meiner gesamten Vergangenheit
kristallisiert
und hätte sich manifestieren
und entfalten können.
Es ist schon
die grösste Enttäuschung
der letzten fünf bis zehn Jahre.
* Zögerliche,
melancholische Gitarrenklänge *
Sie wollten
ganz viel Raum einnehmen,
zwei Hallen und noch eine Wohnung.
Das war schon ein wichtiger Faktor,
weshalb sie uns nicht überzeugten:
Sie haben eine breite
Bedürfnisabklärung gemacht,
aber sie konnten diese Bedürfnisse
nicht in ein architektonisches
Konzept überführen,
das innerhalb einer Halle
zu realisieren ist.
Das hat vielleicht auch irritiert
mit ihrer Hallenwohnen-Erfahrung.
Da könnte man denken,
dass aus dieser Erfahrung
der Umgang mit Räumen,
Ruhe- und Lernzonen anders wäre,
und wie man die Bedürfnisse
innerhalb eines Raums abbilden kann.
Dass sie darauf keine Antwort
gefunden haben, hat uns enttäuscht.
Das war mit einer der Hauptgründe
für die Absage.
Die anderen Gruppen
haben es mit ihren Unterlagen
und der Präsentation geschafft,
eine Vision aufleben zu lassen, die
wir vor unseren Augen sehen konnten.
Da sind die Zur Wölkler
leider zu diffus geblieben.
Es bleibt noch ein Monat
bis zum Auszug.
Die letzte gemeinsame Putzaktion
läuft.
Seraina und Matthias
machen die Halle,
Nora ähm ...
... ist abwesend
und macht später die kleine Bühne.
Sie hat schon damit angefangen.
Ähm ...
Wer heute schwänzt,
hat einfach etwas recycelt.
Heute entspannen sie.
* Ferne, suchende Klavierklänge *
90° drehen!
Jetzt haben wir ganz viel geputzt.
- Warum?
Und ich habe mein Zimmer
hierhergerollt. - Warum?
Das ist eben toll,
jedes Mal kann man woanders sein.
Mätti hat die Hoffnung
auf das Hallenwohnen im Zollhaus
noch nicht aufgegeben
und hat mit der Projektgruppe
Zur Wolke
um eine Aussprache
mit der Jury gebeten.
Wir möchten sehen,
ob es ein Entgegenkommen gibt,
einen Funken Goodwill,
eine gesichtswahrende Lösung.
Jetzt gehen wir an die Aussprache
und hoffen, dass es positiv wird.
Das Filmteam wurde gebeten,
während der Aussprache
keine Tonaufnahmen zu machen.
* Leise Verkehrsgeräusche, Sirene *
Ich fühle mich
einmal mehr gedemütigt.
Am Schluss stellten wir die Frage:
Sollten die beiden Teams,
die noch im Rennen sind, aussteigen,
würden sie es dann erwägen,
auf uns zurückzukommen?
Die Antwort war ziemlich negativ:
Sie würden es eher
leer stehen lassen, für Büros nutzen
oder es selbst machen.
Ich finde das einen Affront.
Wir haben versucht zu sagen,
dass wir aus der Erfahrung heraus
den Raum
als sozialen Raum anschauen,
nicht nur als architektonische
Gestaltung von 4 m hohen Hallen.
Wir wissen,
dass das die Kerngrösse ist:
Man muss es
mit Menschen beleben können.
Ich finde es wirklich skandalös,
total ungerecht.
Ja, das ...
- Sorry, ich bin sehr emotional.
Das ist bitter, bitter, bitter.
Aber ... vielleicht haben wir ...
keine Ahnung.
Vielleicht
haben wir uns zu sehr engagiert,
vielleicht stand zu viel
auf dem Spiel. - Ja, klar.
Seid ihr auch rausgelaufen?
Wir drei, ja.
Die anderen diskutieren noch.
(Eva) Gut. Tschau.
- Tschüss zusammen.
Auch wenn es keine Zukunft
im Zollhaus zu geben scheint:
Die Hallenbewohnerinnen
und -bewohner müssen abbauen.
Passend zum Thema Auszug erscheinen
alle ausgezogen zum Sonntagsbrunch.
(Frau) Alle an die Scheibe.
- Stimmt, Hintern an die Scheibe.
Kommt, das machen wir!
(Frau) Aber du, dein T-Shirt
kannst du ja auch ausziehen.
* Lachen, Stimmengewirr *
Wir haben in der Abstimmungskampagne
bei Züri autofrei
mal eine Aktion gemacht:
Flitzen statt Rasen.
Da sind wir im Winter
zu 50. nackt durch Zürich geflitzt.
Flitzen statt Rasen
ist ein gutes Motto.
Dann waren wir in allen Zeitungen,
"South China Morning Post" usw.
* Stimmengewirr, Lachen *
Aus meiner Sicht
ist das Hallenwohnen ...
... nicht für jeden, klar.
Aber es ist nicht
für jemanden Bestimmtes.
Das Wichtigste ist,
Lust an einer Gemeinschaft zu haben.
Und auch ...
Die Chancen,
die ein solches Wohnen schafft,
sollte man erkennen,
nutzen und lieben.
* Komplizierte Melodie *
* Fernes Lachen *
Wir haben eine Wohnung gefunden, in
die wir zu siebt einziehen können.
Das ist super,
aber es ist eine normale Wohnung -
mit Küche, Badezimmer,
und alles funktioniert.
Das ist komisch für uns alle.
Aber sie
ist auch nicht die Endstation.
Wir sind immer noch auf der Suche
nach einer Halle, die uns passt.
Wenn uns eine in die Hände fällt,
nehmen wir sie und bauen etwas auf.
(Kind) Heiss. Mega, mega heiss.
Heisse Schraube?
- Ja.
Gell. - Wenn wir sie rausnehmen,
wird sie warm.
Ist die am heissesten?
So.
* Schraube klappert. *
Ich werfe sie rein.
- Du musst sie nicht rumwerfen.
Ich werfe sie rein, in den Mund.
- Ach so, in den Mund des Haifischs.
Wir haben eine Übergangslösung
in einer anderen Halle gefunden.
In der Nähe von Belas Kita.
Wir wollen die Kinder dort behalten.
Wenn so viel ändert,
soll zumindest das nicht ändern.
Hier sind wir in einer Grauzone:
Wir durften uns nicht anmelden.
Das ist eigentlich
eine Ateliergemeinschaft,
nicht eine Wohnung,
wo man den Wohnsitz hat.
Mit Kindern
ist das nicht mehr möglich.
Man muss dort zur Schule,
wo der Wohnsitz ist.
Hallo!
Oi! Sigi ist auch dort? Sehr gut.
Er ist allein gekommen.
- Da staunt man, was?
Hast du deine Sachen
schon umgezogen?
Ja, habe ich.
Alle Spielsachen?
- Ja.
Loslassen!
Für mich kommt es
nicht so auf den Raum an -
es braucht keine Halle zu sein.
Es kann auch eine Baracke
oder ein relativ normales Haus sein.
Es braucht einfach viele Menschen,
die man kennt, mit denen man lebt.
In jeglicher Konstellation.
Das ist mir wichtiger
als die Architektur ringsherum.
Gut!
Slowly, slowly, slowly. Fingers!
Well done!
Thank you.
Der Raum wird jetzt aufgegeben.
All das wird eingelagert,
aussortiert.
Es ist noch hart -
wir hatten eine gute Zeit hier.
Und äh ... ja. So ist das.
Mal schauen, was als Nächstes kommt.
* Klirren *
* Er pfeift eine Melodie. *
* Gitarrenschrummen *
* Aufnahme von Vogelgeräuschen,
Gitarre *
* Leises Klappern, Rascheln,
* Die Gitarre verklingt. *
Das ist unsere Wohnung.
Wir haben zwei Etagen im Haus:
zweimal vier Zimmer -
sieben Schlafzimmer.
Wir sind also eine Siebner-WG -
für mich eine relativ kleine WG.
Es ist eine normale Wohnung
mit weissen Wänden und Parkett.
Es ist nicht wie vorher.
Ja.
Das ist schon anders:
ein Zimmer, das schon da ist,
wenn du einziehst - mit einer Tür.
Es ist gemütlich hier -
manchmal etwas zu gemütlich.
Wir haben alles selbst eingerichtet,
nach unserem Gusto.
Trotzdem hat jeder
noch etwas gebaut,
auch wenn es etwas Kleines ist.
Es ist ziemlich entspannt, in
einer normalen Wohnung zu wohnen.
Man hat etwas mehr Zeit für sich,
weil man nicht ständig im Zuhause
Veranstaltungen und Sitzungen hat
und in der Gruppe
etwas zusammen macht.
Ich habe jetzt viel mehr Freizeit -
das merke ich.
Aber wir haben halt keinen Raum mehr
für solche Dinge.
Jetzt ist es halt wirklich eng.
Irgendjemand schaut immer einen
Film, kocht, putzt oder hört Musik.
Man hat keine Ecke,
um selbst etwas zu machen.
Diese Lampe
ist aus der Halle mitgekommen.
Sie stand jahrelang im WC.
Die mussten wir einpacken.
Ich glaube,
diese Blumen kamen auch mit.
Du findest überall Details,
die wir mitgenommen haben.
* Dynamische Klänge *
Das Hallenwohnen
war dieses Jahr ein grosses Thema.
Wir hatten zwei Gruppen ausgewählt.
Die Architekturstudenten
zogen sich im Frühling zurück,
die Familie blieb dabei.
Im Juli mussten wir
einen Zwischenhalt machen
und sagen, dass es so nicht geht,
wie wir es geplant hatten.
Das war für uns schon ein Schock.
Wir machen den Bewerbungsprozess
noch mal komplett auf.
Es können sich alle wieder bewerben.
Für die Ausschreibung machen wir
die maximale Unterteilung.
Statt zwei XL-Hallen,
die wir ausgeschrieben hatten,
werden wir zwei L-, zwei M-
und zwei S-Hallen ausschreiben.
Auch ganz neu ist:
Die Gruppen, die sich bewerben,
müssen
den ganzen Bewilligungsprozess,
die ganze bautechnische Planung
nicht machen,
sondern werden in ihren Wohnungen
eigentlich nur noch
mit innenarchitektonischen Fragen
konfrontiert.
Das ganze Bautechnische
nehmen wir ihnen ab.
Wir haben im ganzen Prozess
sehr viel gelernt
und mussten realisieren,
dass wir auch etwas blauäugig waren
und überschätzt haben,
was man mit selbstorganisierten,
ehrenamtlichen Gruppen hinkriegt.
Diese Information
hat uns kürzlich erreicht
und gleich in Stress gestürzt.
Wir haben immer noch Hoffnung,
dass es letztlich
eine Möglichkeit gibt,
in der wir eine Rolle spielen -
deshalb habe ich das Zollhaus
noch nicht ganz aufgegeben.
Wir sind auf den Philippinen,
auf einer kleinen Insel.
Wir erleben hier eine Auszeit
mit dem Motto:
Familie, Strand, Meer und Dschungel.
(Eva) Amun, gleich gibt's Frühstück.
Mh!
Es ist ein Einzimmerhaus
mit abgetrenntem WC.
Eine Matratze am Boden ist
für die Kinder und wir haben eine.
Aber es ist sehr simpel.
Wir haben zu Hause keine Fixkosten.
Wir haben keine Wohnung mehr,
für die wir Miete zahlen müssten.
Wir haben nur noch einen Keller,
in dem all unsere Sachen sind.
Man kann auch
die Krankenversicherung
für die ganze Familie sistieren
und über eine deutsche Reise-
versicherung viel billiger haben.
Unsere kleine Hütte
kostet 300 Fr. pro Monat.
Die Hütte hat wirklich
einen niedrigen Standard.
Doch der Garten
und der Aussichtspunkt
verleihen ein Gefühl von Freiraum.
Daneben sind Fischer oder Kinder,
die einfach reinkommen.
Oder jemand, der seine Kuh
und sein Kalb durchs Meer führt,
das dann immer
bei uns im Garten landet.
Es hat hier wieder etwas Ähnliches.
Ganz ehrlich
vermisse ich gerade nichts.
Ich finde es jetzt einfach gut,
nicht langweilig,
ich geniesse es.
Wir denken aber darüber nach, was
wir wollen, wenn wir zurückkommen.
Dann ist es für mich ...
Ich merke, dass ich
gern wieder hallenwohnen möchte.
Ob sie das Hallenwohnen im Zollhaus
leben werden, ist noch offen.
Sicher ist:
Die Genossenschaft Kalkbreite
will das Experiment Hallenwohnen
in Angriff nehmen.
SWISS TXT AG / Access Services
Meret Hachen - 2019